now weirdly we have sort of met we have
kind of met
yeah not on the show this is my first
time on i'm a little nervous so forgive
me if i ramble
but we i was doing um a broadway show
called hedwig and the angry inch
and you i had heard that you were going
to be in the audience
and it was this really nasty kind of
rock and roll uh
punk rock musical and you had sat in the
very
very front row if i'm not in the middle
in the middle of i didn't book these
tickets
now and you were with two other guys and
during the show there's a part where
where hedwig who's pretty randy and
nasty um
uh you know there's a good picture of
her she uh
she crawls in on down to the stage and
just picks someone in the audience and
makes out with them
so um i started down i i scanned the
crowd
i saw you i went right for you and i you
know i grabbed my tongue down your
throat
i i have the taste of cheap lipstick in
my mouth for the rest of the show
so nice to meet you on this second day
nice to talk to you
you